I grew up in Hollywood I grew up in the
movie business my father was a studio
executive for something like 45 years my
mother was his secretary for a while and
then became a story editor and she ended
up typing scripts for preston sturges
and working with some extremely
important people in the movie business
when she and my father lived in New York
so I grew up here my father was a studio
executive at Paramount Pictures I spent
every Friday night of my life that I can
remember as a child on the Paramount lot
seeing movies in the executive screening
room so it's very hard to remember the
first movie I saw because it's sort of
like asking when when did you first eat
solid food I don't have any memory of a
time when I wasn't seeing movies I know
I saw Sabrina the original Sabrina in
that executive screening room i know i
saw some like it hot there i know i saw
North by Northwest there i know i saw
rear window there and thought those were
some of the ones that really excited me
but i went to the movies all the time i
went with my friends i went with my
brother i went to the lorena theater in
encino which of course isn't there
anymore in the studio city theatre which
of course isn't there anymore and
sometimes my brother and i would take
the bus into hollywood i don't even know
if my parents knew that on Sunday
afternoons and I think the movie that
probably had the biggest impression on
me as a child was South Pacific which
was one of those movies that he and i
saw on Hollywood Boulevard it was the
first time I really understood the power
of moviemaking of what could happen when
you combine serious drama outrageous
comedy musical numbers the death of a
leading character I thought that was
against the law to kill off somebody
that you liked in a movie I was stunned
when that happened and I was aware even
then even as a child of the structure of
that movie of the the power of a guy
shows up at this place and somebody says
oh you want to go to Valley High and he
says no I have a job to do I'm going to
go over here and do this and then in
order to do that job he has to get the
help of a meal but Emile's falling in
love with Nellie and so Emil
says no I'm not going to do the job with
you because he says no to him the first
guy can go back to bally highly there's
a there's a ballet in that movie between
yes and no that I was really aware of as
a child and the the structure of that
ending that allows you to think that a
meal is dead so the power of when he
turns up alive oh man but there isn't
anything more exciting than that